born with a spinal defect ten-year-old
Eamon sannan says he spent almost half
his life in pain due to my pain
sometimes I couldn't sit in study in
other times I couldn't go out and play
with my friends an end to a suffering is
in sight he's among 30 Yemenis airlifted
out of the capital sana on two un
chartered flights they're receiving
medical treatment in Jordan they've
waited years for I feel glad I got the
opportunity to come here for treatment
but if other Yemenis could come here for
treatment too I would feel better this
is the first time in more than three
years that Yemenis have been allowed to
fly from the capital Sena for medical
treatment abroad Senna is controlled by
the Houthis but Yemeni airspace is
controlled and a blockade imposed by the
saudi-led coalition at war with the
Houthis for the past five years the
blockade has made it challenging for
humanitarian organizations to assist
Yemenis in need the UN and the World
Health Organization or whu-oh joined to
negotiate with the saudi-led coalition
to make the emergency evacuations
possible the w-h-o says the war has
shattered Yemen's health care system
more than half of all hospitals aren't
fully operational many medical workers
have fled abroad and the blockade has
created a shortage of medical supplies
when I'm safe we were very depressed and
annoyed because you have a patient you
can't help we were willing to sell
whatever we had to get treatment in
Yemen but in Yemen there are no
specialized centers for treatment samira
el mar has already had the first of
several operations needed to reconstruct
her ear injured in an accident
she says she spent almost six years
feeling self-conscious about her injury
like I was not feeling good and when I
went to school I was feeling shy because
my ear was deformed the w-h-o hopes
these medevac flights will be the first
of many but the need is great an
estimated 30,000 Yemenis are waiting and
praying for it
take it out to receive proper medical
care
Natasha came al Jazeera I'm man